you know the rules and how to play but
now it's time to see the ideas you have
learned put into action in an actual
game in this game we'll see how two
pieces working together can be a
powerful force in that a king surrounded
by pieces isn't always safe
let's take a look white begins the game
with E for controlling the center in
opening up lines for the Queen and
LightSquared Bishop black plays c6 a
move we haven't seen yet the idea is to
prepare the move d5 on the next turn and
attack the strong pawn on e4 white plays
d4 controlling more space in the center
and also opening up the dark squared
Bishop black strikes back in the center
with d5 threatening to capture the pawn
on e4 on the very next move when the
opponent threatens to take one of our
pieces it's natural to feel worried
remember it's okay to make even trades
such as a pawn for a pawn what you don't
want is to give away your pieces for
nothing in this situation white could
push the pawn forward with E 5 white
could capture the pawn on d5 or as in
the game protect the pawn and develop a
piece with Knight to c3 after D takes e4
Knight takes e4 White's Knight
recaptures the pawn and moves directly
into the center black now plays Knight
to d7 developing a knight in also
preparing the next move Knight G to f6
with the idea that if the knight gets
captured Black is ready to recapture the
knight like that the drawback to this
move is the LightSquared bishop is
blocked and also notice blacks King has
no moves we'll take a look and see if
that becomes a problem white plays
Bishop to c4 activating the bishop to a
powerful diagonal and as you know
pointing out the weakest point in blacks
camp f7 black plays Knight G to f6
attacking White's knight in white plays
Knight to g5 avoiding the Knights attack
in joining the LightSquared bishop in
attacking the f7 square in this position
black should play e6 blocking the light
squared bishop Spath to the f7 square
but black does not have a sense of
danger in the position and plays h6
attacking the knight in assuming that
it's going to move backwards can you
find the move that immediately wins the
game for white that's right Bishop takes
f7 white delivers checkmate threatening
to capture the King on the next turn and
notice blacks king is surrounded or
should we say smothered by its own
pieces it cannot escape the attack
you've learned a lot so far can you put
your ideas into action let's prove it in
the challenges